joining us is Charles Kimball he is the
author of when religions when religion
becomes evil and he's joins us today
from winston-salem North Carolina good
morning mr. Kimball good morning Connie
nice to be with you let me ask you first
your you your history in taking a look
at the area of the Middle East and
specifically in in Iran well I've lived
in the Middle East in 77 78 in Egypt as
part of my doctoral work I was very
actively involved in the Iranian hostage
crisis Act that's what you're referring
to in the first few weeks of the hostage
crisis I was one of a small number of
religious leaders I was actually a
doctoral student I was not a major
religious leader as the others in the
group were in that early part of the
hostage crisis the Iranian government
the US government were not talking to
each other in the the Ayatollah Khomeini
and others indicated they were willing
to meet with some American religious
leaders and so we were there was a small
group of us seven who were invited to
Iran to meet the Ayatollah the student
militants and the embassy compound
various religious and political leaders
in an effort to began to build some
bridges of communication to look for
nonviolent ways out of that obviously
very very intense situation you were 29
years old I was what was the experience
like well it was obviously a very
powerful experience as many viewers will
recall this was a very intense situation
it turned out to be a 444 day crisis and
nominated our news certainly in the
United States for all of that time that
was virtually the only thing covered it
seemed for a while my experience in Iran
was often very different than what I
experienced watching American television
this was a country very much in
revolution earlier that year early in 79
was when the Shah of Iran went on
vacation as he put it and the Ayatollah
Khomeini returned it was a nation very
much in turmoil as most revolutionary
situations are where a lot of different
groups that had come together
in their revolution against the Shah
were then vying for power and many of
them turning on one another and so there
was a fair bit of chaos and a lot of a
struggle for power in those early months
they had presidential election
parliamentary elections and other things
going on and all of that was complicated
of course by the the hostage crisis
which threw everything else into a
tailspin as well how did those
experiences impact you as you were
writing this book when religion becomes
evil over 20 years later well I think
the the experience is there and my
subsequent experiences in Middle East I
lived in the Middle East I've traveled
there more than 40 times particularly
during throughout the 1980s my academic
work as a student of comparative
religion a student of Islam and my work
in the Middle East particularly during
the 1980s I worked with the National
Council of Churches coordinating relief
and development projects as well as
public policy advocacy for the Middle
East and so a variety of things I think
have come to shape the way I view the
world and particularly issues in the
Middle East so there's there are
personal dimensions my part of my family
a large part of my family is Jewish that
shaped some of the way I see the world
I'm actually an ordained Baptist
minister that takes some of how I see
the world to be sure but my academic and
experiential engagement with the with
the region and with issues here in the
United States pertaining to religion and
politics and religion politics the
Middle East all come to bear but I would
say at the base of your question sure
the experience of that very intense
situation in Iran was very foundational
and and at least encouraging me and many
other people I think to try and
understand more of what's going on how
do we make sense of these very
tumultuous movements and developments
and this this rise of a political Islam
that certainly has taken root and
manifests itself in a lot of different
ways including some very violent
destructive ways in our world today and
what conclusion did you come to well
that it's a very tumultuous time and
it's going to continue to be but things
are changing the and some of this has to
be I think said in the larger
in the sense that we're coming out of a
colonial era most people in the United
States don't think of it in these terms
but when you spend a lot of time in the
Middle East you get a little bit longer
view of history and many of the
countries that exist in the world today
are countries that didn't exist 60 or 70
years ago they came about just in the
last hundred years particularly with the
breakup of colonial powers and so we see
all kinds of problems in the nation
state system some of them are manifest
in ways that that are very obvious if we
just simply stop and look a little more
deeply at particular situations where
you have unrepresentative borders so you
have rulers who were empowered not by
virtue of popular consent they might
have been set up by a departing colonial
power they might have taken power by a
military coup or any number of things
you have to get into the particulars of
specific situations that we see people
reacting to and so there are deep roots
in the history of the region and that's
one reason why religion becomes such a
volatile force because many Muslims are
certainly looking to Islam as a way to
provide a framework to move into that
future in a more hopeful way and there's
a lot of disagreement about even among
Muslims as to what that means but
there's a long history of Christian
involvement in the area too with
Crusades and with colonial powers and
with the current superpower influence in
the region our governments influence in
the region all those things come to bear
and religion gets connected to events in
all kinds of way so I don't think
anybody can look into the future with a
crystal ball or nobody has a magic wand
to say X Y & Z are going to happen
definitely we're in a time of great
change in turmoil and part of the
challenge is to understand the forces at
work and make the best choices we can
individually and collectively to find a
way forward to a more hopeful and
healthy future you have in your book
called what you what you call five
morning signs that if faith is might be
turning corrupt what are they in general
what I'm doing in the book is really
looking at what are the warning signs of
religion going to rivalin is a very
powerful and pervasive force one of if
not the most powerful and pervasive
force in human society the vast majority
of people who
lived and who are alive today perceived
themselves to be religious and religion
has inspired people to their highest and
noblest best and as we know sadly
religion has been the excuse or the
justification for some of the worst
things that human beings have done to
one another historically and some of
that is obvious in the activities today
of say suicide bombers operating under
the banner of Islam my premise my
approach is to ask a question to take a
step back a friend a wise friend once
said to me when you're standing on the
edge of a cliff progress is not defined
as one step forward and so my goal is to
take a step back and say and in the wake
of the events especially of September
11th what is it that we can learn as we
look across the different religious
traditions and we look through the
centuries what can we learn about the
ways that that people who perceive
themselves as very sincere end up using
religion for violence and destructive
purposes and and these become all the
more acute in a world filled with
weapons of mass destruction where small
numbers of people can wreak havoc
literally on a global scale so I have
these five warning signs I've identified
the first one is absolute truth claims a
kind of absolutism that often
accompanies religious worldviews that I
think can become very very dangerous
it's not to say that truth is relative I
think truth is profoundly important and
truth claims are profoundly important in
religion but when you move into the area
of absolutism when you believe you can
demonstrate I do demonstrate I think
that anybody who thinks they have God in
their pocket that they know exactly what
God wants for them and for everybody
else potentially can do anything and can
justify it because they're doing God's
will and we see that happening in
various religious traditions throughout
human history so whatever your truth
claim it needs to be tempered by a
measure of humility to recognize that we
are human beings that nobody has el
truth nobody has the mind of God
nobody has perfect inside and wisdom and
so we are all in a process of growing
and learning and changing so temper your
truth claims with a strong measure of
humility and recognize if I may quote
the Apostle Paul
here in the New Testament Paul says we
see through a glass darkly not yet face
to face and I think Christians as well
as Muslims and others need to always
bear that in mind that we have a lot of
limitations in the way we see and
perceive truth and so that should show
temper and measure with our approach I'm
more briefly the other the other signs
are blind obedience the tendency in most
traditions for very charismatic leaders
with few checks and balances to recall
for kind of blind obedience of followers
and that's a very dangerous dynamic you
have to always think for yourself and
never entrust others ultimately to think
for you there's a very interesting
dynamic I think that I hope we have a
chance to explore it a little bit where
there's that what I call the pursuit of
the ideal time and every religious
tradition there is this notion that the
the world is not perfect that there's
something terribly wrong and this is
fundamental to all religious traditions
if we weren't ignorant we wouldn't need
the Buddha to enlighten us if we weren't
sinful we wouldn't need Jesus to save us
from our sins forgetful we wouldn't need
the revelation that God brings through
the Prophet Muhammad and others and so
the premise is that something is wrong
and we work in this world all traditions
teach this that have stood the test of
time to work for a better day of peace
and justice but there is this notion too
of an ideal time that will soon come
that a messiah figure will bring upon us
and so when people think they're on the
verge of that ideal time they begin to
justify all kinds of things even violent
destructive things this is not unrelated
in fact it's directly related I think to
some what's going on and the the view
the theological view we see and the Left
Behind series this wildly popular
premillennial dispensational
fundamentalist view of christianity that
is very very popular today another sign
is the end justifying any means it's
very common that in religious life
something that's important will elevate
to a status of kind of sanctity divine
sanctity and that becomes the end in and
of itself quick example in the Roman
Catholic Church scandal and there are
many other examples one could cite we
see that a common theme that runs
through there was many tragic cases all
over
the United States is the the concern to
protect the institution of the church
that became for many people
well-intentioned religious leaders that
became the kind of end in and of itself
we we can't let one bad apple spoiled us
ruptal all the good things we're doing
with the orphanages and old-age homes
etc etc and so there's the this this
danger of letting one particular thing
become the sort of goal in and of itself
and then justifying behavior around that
that ends up often in disaster as we saw
in that case and finally declaring holy
war my argument is that most people
don't know very much even within the
traditions about the idea of war and say
the Christian tradition the pacifist
tradition the Just War tradition and the
crusade tradition and the the
underpinnings of those and certainly in
Islam the idea of jihad or holy war as
it's often being used now is is a
confused and confusing reality that many
people are using for political purposes
my argument is it's far past time that
people of faith religious people lay war
at the feet of God that if we can make a
case for military action in a particular
setting then make that case but we
should have learned at this point in
time that throughout history people are
always claiming that God is on their
side and God wants them to go to war and
do X Y & Z we have to simply stop this
kind of declaration of holy war and
justifying our behavior as though
somehow this is what God wants us to do
to the phones Miami Florida's first step
go ahead
yes brother Kimble judgment begins at
the house of God and we're not to let
our good be evil spoken up and you know
there's a lot of reaping that's going to
be done because God has been good to
America and we have been the biggest
hypocrites and we first must show
compassion and when we think about on
the road where the the gentleman that
was treated by the Good Samaritan and
this is something that we are going to
read what we have sown but I can
understand your theories and your
principles your analogies
which are very good on target and we
need to respect others religion we need
to give other people time we need to
work together we need to not think of
ourselves but think of a bigger picture
like you say this war the holy war is
the real war let God let go and let God
mr. Kimble well I think that the caller
makes a very good point that those to
whom much is given much is expected and
and I think we do not only as people of
faith but citizens of the United States
whether or not one is personally
religious Jewish Hindu Muslim Christian
and it's important to underscore that
that the United States is the most
religiously diverse country in the world
now the most the most complex Buddhist
city in the world is Los Angeles
California so we have to acknowledge
that the United States is a very diverse
in pluralist society and should be and
we should celebrate that but we are also
the most fortunate people in the world
in many ways too because of the
incredible resources and freedoms and
opportunities and I think that imposes
upon us especially as the world's most
powerful nation economically politically
militarily to to lead the world into a
more hopeful future and I think part of
that for me begins with religious
underpinnings moral foundation that I
find in my own tradition but certainly
it's present in other traditions as well
and the United States and we as citizens
bear a huge responsibility it put it
this way it makes a big difference when
our government does something in our
name it really affects people all over
the world in a way that if I were a
citizen of Sri Lanka or Switzerland or
Sweden it wouldn't have the same impact
those are perfectly fine countries but
their governments don't sneeze and
everybody else catches a cold and so it
potent I think imposes a special
responsibility on us as citizens of the
United States whatever our faith or no
faith background to be as responsible as
we can to advocate for things that we
think are in not only our interest but
ER and the broader human interest in the
world today Wellington Delaware good
morning good morning
as my comment is brief they you know
you're right on the money there and I
appreciate this this program this
morning I think it's very interesting in
my opinion religions since there isn't
just one became evil when they decided
that they had to pass their judgments or
their moral standings or how they want
to live their lives on everybody else I
mean I see people gathering in front of
abortion clinics and they consider
themselves to be Christians and people
of moral standing it they are forcing
their judgments on these people that are
making a very tough decision to go into
this abortion clinic and have the
procedure done I think had they read
their own you know as I call it had they
read their own holy handbook they would
have understood that that behavior in
and of itself is wrong that you
shouldn't do that and in history that
seems to be what has been done in the
name of all religions that people can't
just find God and accept it they found
God they now have to look across the
street and say well I want that man to
find God to house Kimball yeah I think I
get into those very issues very strongly
and the absolute truth claims chapter
and even the that not only the bombing
of but some zealous people remember the
Presbyterian minister in Florida who
murdered a doctor at a family planning
or abortion clinic and was later
executed and gleefully so he sounded
like a a suicide bomber who was ready to
meet God I felt what he got did was
exactly the right thing obviously
passions run very high but I think the
caller is getting at a point here that
is very important and that is what I
find at least a lot in various religious
traditions is a kind of insecurity that
people seem to have this need for others
to reflect back to them exactly their
same views to feel more secure in those
views and I think part of the challenge
and I think the the major religious
traditions have been able to do this and
need to work harder at this in the
future is to to find ways to be
authentically rooted in your tradition
people of faith and goodwill but also
open to the movement of God or the
divine however that's understood not all
traditions speak in terms of of God and
theistic sense and to recognize there is
a great deal of diversity even within
the Christian tradition
not to mention across religious lines
and to find ways to be much more
comfortable with our diversity and
pluralism and it really is pretty easy
if you think about it it's very
threatening to a lot of people but if
you think of your own experience for
those who are watching who happen to be
religious your own views have changed
your conception of the divine for
example surely must be different than it
was when you were a five-year-old child
may be different than it was last year
it hopefully will be different than it
will be a year or two from now and it
may be a very abstract and far less
personified notion in other words we're
all in the process of growing and
learning and changing and and so to
demand much less rigidity and doctrinal
purity I think is a helpful thing in the
long run and to recognize that none of
us have it all completely locked down
it's Islam evil are you asking me yes no
Islam is a great religious tradition
that has stood the test of time it's the
second largest religious tradition in
the world Islam inspired one of the
greatest civilizational systems
throughout human history and continues
to be a major influence our own
civilization Western civilization is
very heavily in fact influenced in very
positive ways by Islamic civilization
philosophy medicine mathematics
chemistry horticulture navigation we're
deeply rooted in Islamic traditions that
influenced Western civilization as we
know it certainly there are people today
doing horrific things evil things in the
name of Islam and that's an enormous
problem not only for the world in a
broad sense but it's certainly a major
problem in various parts of the
predominantly Muslim world but it's
incredibly simplistic and I think and
and wrong to label a religious system
that has stood the test of time and
inspired millions and millions of people
at 1.3 billion Muslims in the world
today on the basis of violent extremists
who are operating under the guise of
Islam today Islam is not monolithic any
more than Christianity is and part of
the challenge is to break through these
kind of simplistic stereotypes that
frankly a lot of religious leaders a lot
of people in my own tradition go on
television and make those sort of claims
that I think are extremely damaging and
revealed a great deal of ignorance on
their part Bradenton Florida go ahead
yeah I know my question was all mr.
Kimmel you were in Iran during the
hostage crisis uh there's some
speculations that the current president
of Iran is was in fact one of the
hostage takers is is this your opinion
or do you think he's not and one other
thing the Iranian regime that's in there
now do you think maybe it needs to be
looked at and perhaps taken out thank
you I don't know the answer to whether
or not the president of Medina jawed is
is was one of the hostage takers the
official claim from Tehran is that he
was not there are people who claim to I
have identified him I don't know the
answer that I never met him I met many
of the the leaders of the student
militants who were holding hostages but
I didn't meet him or recognize him at
all but even if he were there were a
number of those people are some of those
people who went on to leadership
positions in the government many of them
into obscurity so it wouldn't be
terribly surprising if that were the
case certainly he has made several
statements at least the way they have
been reported in the West that are very
disturbing to put it mildly very
troubling comments about Israel denying
the Holocaust ludicrous things like this
that undermine his credibility to put it
very mildly and gently but the people in
Washington and our government despite
whatever harsh rhetoric exists know very
well that Iran is a very important
player in the future that this is not
only for strategic assets in Iran but
there is
within Iran a reservoir of connection to
the United States if people who have
read for example Thomas Friedman's
columns two years ago over he went to
Tehran and wrote several columns and
talked about this may be a place of
great hope in fact the Iranians have
been been practicing democracy limited
it has been problematic certainly you've
had a government or religious leaders
who could squelch things deny candidates
the opportunity to run we're seeing some
of that now but you also have a whole
generation of people who've grown up
voting for members of parliament voting
for a president being involved in the
kind of participatory government that
may in fact help set the stage for some
other democratic reform in various other
places so Iran is multi-layered and it's
important to remember too that there are
some deep connections to the West that
at the time the Shah was ousted in 79
there were something like 35 or 40
thousand Iranian students by far the
largest group of foreign students in the
United States were Iranians so there's a
lot of connection historically and I
think there's still some hope that Iran
may in the end prove to be a very
important player and a constructive way
but certainly right now they're their
major problem areas around the President
and certainly the nuclear development
program that has many people in the
world very concerned Wood River Illinois
good morning good morning you know my
favorite definition of religion comes
from the Bible and with the book of
James where he says pure religion that
is undefiled before God and the father
is this to visit orphans and widows and
their affliction and to keep oneself
unstained from the world and it occurs
to me that a lot of the things that
you're saying are very true but why I
always ask what is it we can do because
you know you've got the little old lady
at the soup kitchen
and then you have the intellectuals out
there messing things up and maybe we
should set up the University in Iran or
Iraq that this is dedicated to studying
what's going on you know or maybe even
one here it's just it seems like we lack
any vision of how to to bring peace to
the world
you know we're waiting for Jesus to come
and bring us peace on the one hand but
on the other hand what is the
religion can do can we study something
can we actually do something and come to
some conclusions about the differences
in how to make people understand and
live you know next to one another you
know I lived near st. Louis Missouri and
I noticed an Islamic center
and a poor neighborhood the st. Louis
Missouri and I thought you know there's
nothing going on here you know the
people are living closely down the
street and then up the street were
Christian places what is it we can do
can we get together can we study how to
resolve these issues it make peace with
one another mr. Kimball yeah it's a
wonderful question two things let me say
in response one a striking and I talked
about this in the latter part of the
book one of the striking themes that one
finds in all the major religious
traditions again that have stood the
test of time is that they share a kind
of core understanding it's exemplified
in the words of Jesus actually when
Jesus was asked the greatest commandment
he said to love God with all your heart
and to love your neighbor as yourself
I said in this is all the law and the
prophets and by that he meant this is
the teaching the sum total the teaching
of the Scriptures if you want to boil it
down not unlike the quotation that the
caller read from the book of James you
find that same notion in all the major
religious traditions obviously not from
the lips of Jesus but there is something
to which we owe our very existence God
ultimate reality however it is
understood in most traditions it would
be God but it's understood more broadly
in other ways and that's connected to
the way we relate to other parts of
God's creation and so love God and love
your neighbors yourself and you need
both you have to have both dimensions of
that you can't say I love God and fly an
airplane into a building you're clearly
violating the second part of that kind
of kind of commandment one of the
heartening things that's happened since
September 11th and this relates to his
question as to what we can do as I've
traveled all over the country lectured
all over the country it's amazing the
number of things that are happening in
local communities interfaith councils
there are a lot of places where Jews
Christians and Muslims are coming
together for example to build Habitat
houses a number of cities where this is
going on where congregations are finding
their way together and in the process
putting a real human face on the other a
lot of study programs about Islam
they're exploding all over the place if
you can if you can talk to a local
Muslim leader you'll find they're pretty
Haggard most the time because they're
being invited by churches and by temples
and synagogues to come and talk because
people want to know and understand more
now what we tend to hear a lot more of
on television unfortunately is the
screech e shrill voice from the
religious right there are people in our
country and many of them get a lot of TV
time who are denouncing Islam as a
wicked and evil religion people like Pat
Robertson Jerry Falwell Franklin Graham
it's not a Billy Graham has made this
comment a number of times in public
settings are very unhelpful and a
destructive kind of a comment for these
people to make but there are people on
the right who are digging their heels in
and trying to vilify anything other than
their own worldview but on the other
side what a lot of people are not seeing
quite as visibly is a tremendous
outpouring of effort to find ways to
come together to work in our communities
because a lot of people are waking up to
the fact that not only do we live in a
religiously and culturally very diverse
world but our local communities are in
fact microcosms of that very world
community and so the challenges we face
globally are very much the challenges we
face in our local communities and a lot
of good things are going on right now
and I hope that will be some of the
positive benefit of the dangers we see
by events on the international scene dr.
Charles Campbell is joining us this
morning from winston-salem North
Carolina he has been at Wake Forest
since 1996 and he's a professor of
comparative religion in the department
of religion and the Divinity School at
Wake Forest University next is
Cincinnati good morning yeah religion is
simply an extension of man's personality
and we here in this country are
basically using religion for the
conservative movement is using it as a
political tool Bush you know saying he's
religious yet he's responsible for 50
thousand maybe hundred thousands of
people in Iraq when you look at poverty
and and globalization you and you look
at these terrorists I I wrote a book and
I basically saved
that these terrorists that the terrorism
comes from poverty that the way that you
you defeat terrorism is you can use
religion or whatever but but in reality
what you have to do is bring those
people out of poverty so so when you
look at these the Muslims you look at
people that are that are an absolute
poverty not the poverty that you and I
know which would be controlled poverty
food stamps whatever and and I think
that that those people are just grasping
for anything and and and and as if they
have nothing to grasp or they end up
with a religion and if you look at the
Muslims afterlife that they they
emphasize afterlife because this life is
so horrible for them the absolute
poverty so you look at you look at
George Bush and you look at Tom DeLay
who are supposed to be born-again
Christians in there they're absolutely
evil people and and and and the more
power they become the more evil they
become which is attached to this
religion like I say it's it's it's it's
it's probably the nastiest institution
on the face of the earth while at the
same time you know it's a half a percent
of the population on both sides that
caused these problems thanks nettie mr.
kimball well I I see who I wrote a book
there are three or four questions or
comments woven into that which are all
very important and substantial I would
say that he's right very much right in
the sense that the sources of violence
and extremism the sources of terrorism
are many but I believe they are often
very much rooted in the particulars of
circumstances and economic circumstances
have been a key determining factor for
example lack of political opportunity
horrific human rights situations things
that contribute to a kind of
hopelessness have certainly been a very
important and powerful factor at least
in the early stages of violent extremism
and suicide bombing and so forth and so
the longer term and this is this is one
of the real challenges related to the
policies our government now pursues the
longer term
challenges relate to drying up this
swamp that is the that is the the
nurturing point for violence and extreme
extremism when people see very little
hope do people use religion for
political purposes obviously the answer
is yes
it's very obvious to see it in various
parts of the world we saw Saddam Hussein
get religion in 1991 when he saw things
going badly in Kuwait he suddenly got
very religious and started talking about
liberating Jerusalem and and even today
the Iraqi flag has Allah ho Akbar on it
as an ironic sort of twist for a secular
government in in Iraq he was pulling up
the religious heartstrings in any way he
could and this is something that we see
politicians do all the time was very
much a part of our 2004 presidential
election as we saw both sides trying to
figure out how best to play to religious
sympathies and and religion very easily
I think gets corrupted the caller makes
a very good very good point the notion
that a better afterlife motivates people
it's certainly the case in many
religious traditions but you have to be
again careful about monolithic sort of
claims some of the poorest nations and
poorest people in the world are Muslims
and some of the wealthiest per capita
are Muslims as well and and everything
in between
you can look within the Christian
tradition look at the old spirituals
during the slave period and you'll see
the major theme is afterlife those are
songs of people who saw very little hope
in this world but hoped that there would
be some kind of justice on the other
side and that's rooted in certain
biblical images and notions too so these
kind of views are wedded to and a part
of a religious tradition but only part
of it and one has to be careful about
generic statements I think that they
simply don't apply to everybody in the
whole religious tradition Springfield
Missouri good morning good morning I
like to yeah
I command mr. Campbell for his effort to
build a peaceful world now I am a Muslim
I can become almost him if I don't
believe in our brother Jewish and our
brother Christianity
okay second thing you know we hear a lot
from the politician about jihadist yet
yeah yeah you know let me explain what
you had what's mean now mr. Campbell
you don't want the ad which is you
struggle to build a peaceful world
ma'am you struggle to support your
family that's what you had in Islam
means okay and this put our hands
together built peaceful world from
Jewish people Buddhists Indians Muslims
in Christian and also one thing we have
to do miss put our hands together and
god bless you sir and God bless United
States Thank You mo Thank You a couple
of points that he makes that are very
very important I think to underscore one
is certainly the case the Prophet
Mohammed when he talked about jihad he
pointed out that as people came back in
from a military conflict that this is
the lesser jihad the outward struggle in
defense of Islam that is so popular now
in our in our world and media but the
greater struggle he said is the struggle
you have with yourself to know the right
thing and to do it and he put his finger
on a couple of examples of that to
struggle to be the best person you can
be in your family in your work and your
working community those kind of things
that's the big struggle to know the
right and to do it's a reflection of
what we read and and again the writings
of Paul when he says that which I would
do i do not the very thing I would not
do that's what I do it's this struggle
as a human being even when you know what
is right to do what is right the Quran
is also full of references to the people
of the book and there are passages in
the Quran that promise that Jews and
Christians too will have their reward
will be in paradise there are also
passages in the Quran that that on the
surface seem very harsh to attack those
and fight back and kill those who
persecute you and so like any other
religious texts these have to be
understood and interpreted how do you
make sense
these different messages and and that's
a challenge for Muslims to interpret the
passages that people like Osama bin
Laden will seize upon and say you see we
should fight back and kill anybody who
disagrees with me is an infidel and so
we'll cite certain kind of passes that
the challenge to remember is that you
can make any religious text say anything
you want it to say Shakespeare was right
when he said even the devil can quote
scripture according to his purpose we
have to be very careful about lifting
particular things out of context and
this is what people do not only within
religious traditions what people do as
they look at other traditions but within
the Koran there's a tremendous amount
that one can cite and point to a vision
of unity and cooperation recognizing as
the Quran does that Judaism and
Christianity are indeed legitimate
religions people of the book who also
will have their reward Malvern Arkansas
last call go ahead you know I was
talking about Cain and Abel it's talking
about when religion goes bad they both
offered a sacrifice one was received and
the other was not and Cain got mad and
killed Abel and when he come down to the
the Acts of the Apostles it was Saul
watching over Stephen when he was stoned
to death and it was the same spirit in
Saul that caused him to kill Stephen and
that's in and God said the meek shall
inherit the earth and the humble and
those that love their neighbor mr.
kimball any reaction well he does make a
good point that the evil starts early
right there in Genesis where we have the
story of the first murder there's no
question I would go back I think to
something that I said early on and that
is that religion is an extraordinarily
powerful force it has inspired people to
their highest and noblest best in my
view it represents the vast majority of
people in the world are religious and I
think we find our best hope within the
religious traditions that especially
that have stood the test of time
it is also a force that can be used for
destructive purposes and may be part of
what does us all in as well so how we
appropriate and understand religion and
how that intermesh is with our political
understandings both in this country and
in various parts of the world where
those issues are very acute right now
will say a lot not only about the future
of our religious traditions but about
the future of our world dr. Charles
Kimball is professor of comparative
religion in the department of religion
and the Divinity School at Wake Forest
University in winston-salem North
Carolina where he joins us from this
morning thank you very much for your
time Connie nice to be with you thank
you and in just a few moments we'll be
back with the Afghan ambassador to the
United States